[Music]
when I found you I saw raw untamed power
and beyond that something truly special
[Music]
something beside me has always been
[Music]
and I was awake
[Music]
[Music]
I've seen this raw strength only once
before too scared me enough that
it does now
[Music]
for the pastime
kill it
if you have to
that's the only way to become what you
meant to be
[Music]
you're the spark the fire
this is not going to go
[Music]
the way you think
or film
honey
I need someone to show me my place in
all this
[Music]
four animatronics puppetry physical
effects
yeah looks fantastic this is a little
evolution of the crystal fox
[Music]
we'll do a combination of a hand puppet
they'll be animatronics in the face
and then we will make a perfect version
for CGI who will then scan it to be able
to bring her to life in any way that
Ryan wants
[Music]
but the pastime the only way to become
what you meant to be
darkness rises at night to meet
I need someone to show me my place in
all this
come on
is not going to go away you think
[Music]
so good
starwars the last Jedi where the pg13
walking up the ramp walk into the
hallway I flashback to when I was a kid
and with the action figures inside
suddenly I had like a big lump in my
throat
brian is doing many unexpected things
like taking characters in new directions
individual stories of these characters
are elevated but made fresh and new
that's what I love about Brian's
approach to the story it's like a real
journey of discovery
he's and gentlemen welcome to episode 8
[Music]
first time shooting with mark
presumption with Daisy
first time shooting a Star Wars movie
and we got some cool stuff
sad like a dog whimper Ryan's wonderful
personality is all over this film
I've misjudged he has flaws in other
areas I just don't know about
there's the weird thing that happens
minds being built on when you first show
up on it you're kind of over about ropes
by at all and then you get into the
nitty-gritty of working on it ready
action
naturally that level of it goes away and
you find yourself just focus on making
the scene work getting the shots and
then once in a while you're taking a
little break and sitting back and you
look around
to get the holy crap mountain again
concentrators works split up by holy
craps
[Music]
beautiful quite very nice gun
breathe now reach out what I see like
darkness
and something else
it's calling me
resistant ray
[Music]
we do pg-13 everybody sucks episode 8
gosh the first film didn't even have a
number
Ryan has written a story that's
unexpected but right
some of the stuff that happens people
gonna be like oh my god
even though I think I know it all they
throw things have me story-wise I never
could have imagined and even though
everybody knows it's the second in a
trilogy it feels like its own thing
Star Wars is so cool because there's all
these creatures
amazing visual effect
like all the characters are also so
complex
Brian nice Ilocos wiki South's
particular new director Kali vicious
learn or T sound
it feels like the storylines became more
established
we're really getting to know these new
characters
also with the characters that we know
and love
my life's change
everything's being shifted in the
opposite way to what the audience
expected after 7:00
Brian's made Star Wars fresh and new
[Music]
I'm hoping it'll be a little shocking
but I'm hoping it'll feel real and
honest
the comments Asian story of good against
evil
told in the most fascinating way but it
has a real spiritual depth to it
it's about family and that's what's so
powerful about it
you must have a thousand questions
where's ray something inside me is awake
I need help
we are the spark the light the fire with
brains are still tied down I was raised
to fight
for the first time I had something to
fight for
rated pg-13
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Bree
[Music]
just
[Music]
reach out
[Music]
like
[Music]
darkness
the barns
[Music]
[Music]
I only know one truth
it's time for the Jedi to end
[Music]